had someone recently comment on my
youtube channel um
they wanted to know why am i getting
pcos i'm not even 18 years old
so i wanted to create this quick video
on pcos just to explain the simplicity
of it so you
really understand it polycystic ovarian
syndrome
poly means many and then we have the
word
cyst okay many cysts but in reality
it's not true it's not really cyst it's
follicles but i'm not going to get into
that but for right now just understand
that there's these little bumps
growing and there's many of them on the
ovary
okay so we have polycystic ovarian and
then syndrome
now a syndrome is not necessarily a
disease
it's suggestive of a disease but it's a
disorder having
more than one symptom that suggests a
disease okay so
all right what are the symptoms
infrequent
or prolonged menstrual cycle excess male
hormones
as in androgens infertility excessive
hair growth throughout your body
thinning of the hair on your head acne
and insulin resistance now if you look
up this condition on wikipedia
it will give you a lot of general
information
that that is not very helpful uh they'll
talk about the cause being genetic
they'll talk about the cause being
potentially environmental
also they will tell you that pcos has no
cure
but it can be treated with metformin
anytime you're trying to figure out
some mysterious medical condition um
realize that there's usually one key
factor that you need to know to figure
it out
there's one piece of information that
explains
everything and that is rarely if ever
found in wikipedia or the first page
or second page or third page on google
when you do searches
and so one thing that i'm really
interested in is doing videos on that
key
piece of information so you can figure
everything out
with pcos the key piece of information
is this high androgens can be caused by
high levels of insulin okay
that's what you need to know in other
words every single one of these symptoms
right here
is coming from high androgens because
you have high levels of insulin now
what's interesting is that they rarely
ever
check insulin levels they'll check your
blood sugar
levels now you cannot determine what's
happening with insulin
by checking your blood sugars because
you could have normal blood sugars
yet have high levels of insulin because
the insulin resistance will
buffer some of that blood sugar response
until
a certain point where it can't buffer it
and then it can't compensate
and you become a pre-diabetic and a
diabetic
but for right now all you need to know
is that your high androgens
are coming from the high levels of
insulin that's why they treated with
metformin
because metformin treats insulin
resistance which will help regulate your
insulin levels and help normalize them
okay
but what's behind high levels of insulin
well if you're new to my channel i
every almost every single video i have
is related to that one topic
you need to do healthy keto and
intermittent fasting is your primary
eating plan to help you regulate your
insulin levels and then
get your pcos reevaluated because you
are probably going to find that you
have a lot less problems with this
disorder
why because you're getting to the root
cause if you're new to my channel and
you want to know what to do i put a link
down
right below of exactly what you should
be eating
hey before you go real quick i have a
course
entitled how to bulletproof your immune
system
it's a free course i want you to take it
and here's why
here's you here is your
environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here
what about strengthening
your immune system that's what's missing
this course will show you
how to bulletproof yourself and so you
can tolerate and resist your environment
much better
by strengthening your own immune system
i put a link down in the description
right down below
check it out and get signed up today